merck est bas l'amérique est de retour
mais qu'est l'amérique est de retour la
diplomatie est de retour a qu un
discours pour redorer le blason des
états unis joe biden s'est exprimée
cette nuit sur le futur de la politique
étrangère américaine
et pour faire table rase de la
diplomatie mise en place par donald
trump
le président américain a déclaré s'est
entretenu avec vladimir poutine
objectif de cet appel téléphonique
prévenir son homologue russe des
changements à venir dans les relations
entre les deux pays
j'ai clairement dit au président poutine
une façon très différente de mon
prédécesseur que le temps des états unis
se soumettait face aux actes de la
russie avec l'ingérence dans nos
élections
les cyber attaques l'empoisonnement de
ses citoyens il est révolu nous
n'hésiterons pas à augmenter le prix à
payer par la re sic et à dépendre
l'intérêt vital que nous portons à notre
peuple
autre point évoqué lors du discours de
joe biden la chine le président
américain montre les dents et durcit le
ton devant la politique internationale
chinoise
nous allons faire face aux abus
économiques de la chine compterait sa
ligne de conduite agressive pour
repousser des attaques de la chine sur
les droits de l'homme la propriété
intellectuelle et la gouvernance
mondiale
mais nous sommes prêts à travailler avec
pékin quand il est dans l'intérêt de la
mer se le faire enfin joe biden a
annoncé la fin du soutien américain à la
coalition saoudienne dans la guerre au
yémen un engagement salué par ryad qui
affirme son soutien à je cite une
solution politique soit cette guerre
doit cesser et pour souligner notre
détermination nous mettons pas à tout
soutien américain aux opérations
offensives dans la guerre au yémen y
compris aux ventes d'armes sur le plan
migratoire joe biden prend également une
direction drastiquement opposé à son
prédécesseur
les etats-unis accueilleront désormais
125 mille réfugiés par an soit un nombre
d'admissions plus de huit fois supérieur
à celui soudain entre